we have any fans of robots are here
today we're in the year 2020 and reco
foxing is the biggest sport in the world
that was awesome corporate sponsored big
money rules regulations but beyond that
is the underworld
be the main event fight till the death
I just need a little long as much as I
like you do you're a bad bad brother
what was he like as a boxer does
anything charlie is someone who was a
boxer boxing's known on the relevant
people aren't interested in any more
robot boxing as a game and he's trying
to eke out a living you're finally done
cuz you got nothing left what are we
looking for anything anything I could
use to put a fighting back together I
think there's a robot in there
max finds Adam in this junkyard and he
believes that there's something to this
robot I've never seen anything like it
before when we bring him to life it's
probably the most important moment in
the entire film atom becomes the glue
that brings us all together get him a
fight the robots are operated by humans
they have remote controls control panels
high-tech devices Adams big time
function is the shadow function and his
operating system is programmed to mirror
what he sees watch me do what I do we
did motion capture where we had real
boxers choreographed by Sugar Ray
Leonard actually boxing each other Sean
said to me you guys how do you feel that
Sugar Ray Leonard nice like Joe why
don't we just go for the best the
emotion takes over in this thing and all
the sudden these machines like they come
to life and you start talking like that
real Jones of power and that's what the
audience are gonna feel too I'm ready to
fight
real steel
you